we know that we humans need energy to  perform our day-to-day activities and we  consume food in order to get energy  but how do plants survive where do they  get their required energy from  well plants get their required nutrition  from the soil and carbon dioxide around  them  these nutrients are processed by the  plant with the help of chlorophyll in  the presence of sunlight  so basically sunlight plus chlorophyll  plus carbon dioxide plus water gives  energy to the plants in the form of  sugar  this entire process is called  photosynthesis  photo means light and synthesis means to  put together did you know that carbon  dioxide is compressed during  photosynthesis what is the by-product  derived due to this process  please share your answers in the  comments section  if you like this video please like and  share it and subscribe to our channel